hey guys I'm just McDowell here to bring
you another GS news update today get to
combine the last of us on ps4 with a
turkish CNN video games website we're
currently taking bids on which of those
you think is more surprising well
multiplayer the Turkish site in question
is certainly a thing but the report that
the last of us is coming to the new
generation console is still a rumor at
this stage PlayStation turkey BP second
salon said during a video on the gaming
site that the action game is all set to
come to the ps4 as both a physical and
digital release a translation by neogaf
you Sakura has suggested that salon
claimed no sequel is in the works just
yet but the original will land on Sony's
PlayStation 4 we've got no official
confirmation from Sony at this stage so
dirt hold us to the translation of the
Turkish gentleman from the video on the
site you've never heard of but you never
know a ps4 port would be a little
strange though given that the last of us
is currently rumored to be a PlayStation
now title that's the service designed to
stream games from oldest ernie platforms
let me know in the comments whether you
reckon this one's actually going to be a
thing and whether you'd buy a ps4
version of lots of us as brawler other
reviews updates and everything else
gamey you could possibly want keep it
tuned to gamespot